This is super interesting and maybe not completely
surprising to you.
White House data has now leaked, which shows
that the White House knows that infections
are spiking in rural Trump voting areas while
they continue to decline in some of those
early hit disproportionately urban blue voting
areas and the growing political divide that
has long permeated the country when it comes
to attitudes towards coronavirus.
As we know, Democrats much more likely to
be taking the virus seriously than Republicans.
Democrats much more likely to be staying at
home than Republicans.
Democrats much more likely to be wearing masks
than Republicans.
That now, which has been a political divide
for some time, is being reflected in the case
and death.
Growth rates.
Now, the Trump ists will say less than most
of the deaths are still in blue areas.
These liberal cities like New York City and
the surrounding New Jersey towns and cities,
Chicago, Detroit, Boston.
Now, of course, those places also have in
common that they are very dense cities with
huge numbers of direct flights to and from
China and Europe.
So that explains why those places were early
hubs and why they were places with significant
infection early before we had any testing
and before we knew much about the prevalence
and the spread of coronavirus.
But in terms of percentages, which is really
where you have to look if you want to evaluate
a virus, it's called viral spread for a lot
for a reason.
We are now seeing that most of those early
hotspots on a percentage basis are actually
on a decline, whereas some of the fastest
growth rate spots are, for example, Texas,
Florida and Georgia.
Now, just to put some numbers to it, check
out the case growth rates yesterday.
These are not raw numbers.
What you want to look at is the rate of growth,
which is a trajectory.
OK, you look at yesterday, Tennessee, Virginia,
Texas, Georgia and Florida all had dramatically
larger case growth rates than Massachusetts
and New York.
Massachusetts, right at 1 percent.
New York at point 43 percent.
Tennessee, 3.5 percent growth rate yesterday.
And so what you have to understand is that
over time, the raw numbers are going to spike.
You look at Tennessee in cases and you might
say, oh, okay, well, they went from, you know,
600 to 650 cases.
But if that rate continues, it becomes a huge
hotspot very, very quickly.
So that gets us to this leaked data.
The White House has a number of slides which
have leaked that show that this is a trend.
The White House is aware of.
You've got rates decreasing in 14 states,
rates increasing in nine states, but 27 states
don't even have enough testing yet that we
can say for sure that all of the cases are
even close to being counted accurately.
But here is where it gets really interesting.
The state level data may not really be enough
to underscore this.
Dr. Bourke's and others for a while now have
been saying we really need to look at counties.
You need to look at counties to see what's
going on.
That helps us separate urban versus rural.
It helps us separate parts of states from
each other.
It turns out that when you look at the county
level, the biggest spikes are happening in
rural Trump voting counties in places like
Kansas and Tennessee.
Some of those places have seen case growth
rates of more than a thousand percent in a
single week.
There are rural Trump counties in Missouri,
Nebraska, Minnesota, Wisconsin, which lean
heavily trump the counties do where cases
have grown 400 percent.
All but one of the top 10 growth counties
in the last week were Trump counties in 2016.
Dr. John Ross, who's a professor at Harvard
and Harvard Medical School, tweeted about
this, saying, quote, The fastest rising areas
in the U.S. for covered cases are very white
and very trampy.
According to this slide, somebody leaked to
NBC News.
This is why I do not believe that Trump's
strategy of just normalizing the deaths and
pretending we've won is going to work.
It could work for some time.
There's no question about it, because right
now the growth rates are very high and a lot
of these Trump counties, but the raw numbers
are still small.
Few go from 100 to 200 new cases per day to
100 percent increase, but it's still only
200 cases.
It's not going to get as much attention, particularly
when a lot of times people are sorting the
data by most new cases today, which will favor
states with larger populations and states
with.
With early infections.
But if then you go from 200 new cases a day
to four hundred to eight hundred and sixteen
hundred and then cumulative, cumulatively,
you're talking about a huge number of infections.
So what that says to me is the Trump strategy
of saying, we won.
We've prevailed.
We're on the decline.
We've got testing.
We've got everything.
The economy's going to reopen.
Third quarter will be transitional.
Fourth quarter is gonna be amazing.
Twenty twenty one is going to be the best
in history, this type of stuff.
It ignores that if these growth rates continue
another 30 days and we said this 10 days ago
and now a lot of these states are the leaders
in growth rate.
If it's another 30 days of this, you are going
to have very red states that presumably local
news is still going to report on cases and
deaths.
National news is going to point to these states
as the new hot spots.
I don't believe that it is viable for Trump
to simply pretend everything is fine until
November.
If indeed, these places continue spiking.
Also interesting.
Somebody leaked this data.
That means that someone inside the White House
and inside or close to the task force.
I don't mean like Dr. Burke's, but there's
so much staff that's associated up.
They probably decided to leak this because
they realized they need to because of what
the public position of Trump has been.
You see Trump go out and say cases are going
down everywhere and then inside the task force.
They have slides would say that's not true.
And the places where it's growing the fastest
are mostly Trump counties.
You've got Fox News broadcasting.
You know, it's time to go and open and get
back to work.
But a ton of their employees are still working
from home.
What's being said publicly is not matching
up with the policies that a lot of places
are putting in place.
Trump continues to say we don't need to worry
about testing and tracing.
Things are good to go.
Everything's going down.
And yet the White House over the last 72 hours
has put in place a mandatory mask policy and
daily testing for more and more people.
Other than Trump and Pence, of course, they're
not wearing masks.
So they're very clearly saying one thing and
doing something very different when it comes
to the policy behind the scenes.
Meantime, I am very pleased to see that here
in Massachusetts, we had very small case growth
rate for about the last 10 days.
Deaths yesterday were at their lowest since
April 4th, which is about 40 days ago.
Lowest deaths in 40 days was yesterday in
Massachusetts.
That's really, really good to see.
And we're expecting some new guidance probably
in the next 48 hours from Massachusetts Governor
Charlie Baker, who's not been perfect.
He's been late on a bunch of stuff, but he's
been far earlier than more than half of the
country's governors.
We'll see what continues to happen in the
early infection.
Blue states like New York, New Jersey, Massachusetts,
California, Illinois.
And then we're gonna be able to compare and
contrast that was place with places that never
really closed at the state level.
Cities may have done things that have been
very quick to reopen.
We're going to know in the next 20 or 30 days
exactly what the repercussions of that are.
Early data
are
that
it's not going to be particularly pretty.